Welcome back everyone this will be my brand
new ghost rider video marvel had a couple
easter eggs for him during doctor strange too and
during moon knight helping set up the character
they're really quick blink and you'll miss it but
they are really important so if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we're doing a giveaway for disney plus
memberships because obi-wan kenobi episodes are
starting in a couple weeks i'll be doing videos
for all those as well but careful for spoilers
from everything that happened during moon knight
and everything that happened during doctor
strange too the first big ghost rider easter
egg comes during the movie when scarlet witch has
killed most of kamar taj just rolling right over
them like the tide gone full ringu to break out
of the mirror dimension she did not have to go
that hard but she has dr strange and wong dead to
rights and is about to take america chavez's power
until she freaks out so badly that in a panic she
activates her power again opening a portal and dr
strange takes advantage of that they have this
extended scene of both of them screaming while
traveling through many alternate universes
each one very different with their screen
changing pitch just depending on the states of
their physical existence through each universe
each of the different universes are meant to be
big easter eggs and references to different things
i did a complete breakdown of all the separate
universes and what they mean in my full breakdown
video so i'll link that below in the description
if you want to learn about every single one of
the different universes because there's a lot of
them the first easter egg that's important for
ghostwriter is when they're traveling through all
these universes one of them is basically a hell
universe that looks like this you see a version
of new york city that seems like the entire earth
has been consumed by hell like the entire mcu
has been conquered by the marvel fearlords like
mephisto or one of the other giant cosmic demons
and when you think about giant evil cosmic beings
trying to take over the mcu that we've seen in the
past dormammu comes to mind but for instance his
dark dimension looks very different than this hell
type of dimension like they want it to look like
it's a version of hell that has completely taken
over the mcu but in the hell version of new york
you see a bunch of skeletons crawling around in
the background demons fire everywhere skeletons
everywhere so it's like in this universe mephisto
has conquered the entire mcu somehow the other
marvel fearlords for instance are different
from dormammu in that they're basically more
associated with supernatural horror like demons
hell dimensions mephisto for instance rules over
a dimension that's basically the christian ideal
of hell but all these marvel fearlords these giant
cosmic demons and godlike creatures are trying to
conquer the mcu just like dormammu is they just
use different characters to do it the mcu concept
of hell the underworld is where you get to actual
mephisto actual demons and ghost rider the spirit
of vengeance you probably remember the version of
ghost rider they introduced on agents of shield
i did a ton of videos for it back in the day
when they introduced him it was a really big deal
during agents of shill when they had ghost rider
on it was all about a version of the dark cold now
that version of the dark hole looked a little bit
different like the cover was different but that's
because a different creative team was using that
you could say that all that stuff is still
technically canon through the marvel cinematic
multiverse though the multiverse now kind of makes
everything canon they tried to tie in with what
was going on with infinity war and avengers
end game but eventually they were going to do
a full-blown ghost rider tv show spin-off just
for robbie reyes's version kevin feige wound up
cancelling it right before disney plus was created
because they created disney plus and he wanted
to bring everything to their streaming platform
but reportedly he also canceled that because he
wanted to do something different with the ghost
rider character inside the mcu and he's using a
lot of this doctor strange two stuff to set that
up along with moon knight a long time ago kevin
feige said that the doctor strange character just
in general was a really big deal for them because
in doctor strange movies they could introduce more
supernatural horror elements to the mcu and that's
where you get to characters like the midnight suns
ghost rider being one of the big ones that's why
they're introducing the concept of hell here the
underworld the mcu to explain how ghost rider can
exist so that's why you see this hell universe
inside doctor strange too now we know in the mcu
there's an underworld alternate dimension where
demons exist here's where we get to the connection
to the moon knight series and easter eggs we're
talking about ghost rider spirit of vengeance this
alternate dimension this afterlife where demons
exist this hell-like dimension during moon knight
they explain what happens to people in the mcu
after they die their soul their consciousness so
to speak separates from their physical body kind
of like when you're traversing the astral plane
except your physical body winds up being dead
this will really bake your noodle but i think
you were just taking a little time out i'm afraid
you're actually quite dead you'd be surprised
how many intersectional planes of untethered
consciousness exist like the ancestral plane oh
just gorgeous your consciousness then transfers
to a version of the afterlife which actually
winds up being just an alternate dimension based
on each person's belief system or if they formed
a contract with a powerful cosmic being or a god
like ghostwriter and moon knight so moon knight
for instance has a contract with khonshu part of
the egyptian pantheon so even though marc spector
never believed in the egyptian gods he was jewish
to begin with when he formed the contract with
khonshu when they died their personalities died
that's why he wound up in the egyptian version of
the afterlife and the thor characters like odin
for instance all believed in valhalla that's an
alternate dimension where odin just went after he
died the same thing that happened to odin kind of
happened to khonshu and his pantheon they went to
an alternate pocket dimension called the overvoid
that's why when you see khonshu speaking to
marc spector or the other characters he's
speaking across dimensions he can only physically
appear to them inside their head like he's not
actually here physically in the mcu it's the same
way that odin is speaking to thor at the end of
ragnarok he's speaking to him from this alternate
valhalla dimension mephisto for example is the
ruler of an alternate dimension that represents
a more christian concept of hell so when all the
versions of ghostwriter died or they somehow wind
up there through occult means which i'll explain
in a second because they kind of introduced
more occult concepts during doctor strange
too their spirits all wind up there in some way
they form a contract with mephisto giving them
the spirit of vengeance thus becoming ghost rider
the way the ghost rider exists is very similar
to the way that moon knight exists we just saw
that during the episodes when each of them died
a cosmic being wound up taking advantage of them
in some way khonshu for instance took advantage of
marc spector saving him in exchange for becoming
his slave basically same thing is basically true
for a version of ghostwriter with mephisto in the
spirit of vengeance mephisto just taking advantage
of johnny blaze also during the moon knight series
the other ghost rider easter egg is that you see
this flaming ghost rider skull one of the first
times you see koncho appearing to steven grant
ghostwriter was on the midnight suns team that
it seems like they're slowly setting up in the
mcu with blade kit harrington's black knight
character werewolf by night and there were other
characters in the comics that were members of the
team that they cycled the roster a little bit most
of these characters seem like they're supposed
to be crossing over in the blade movie next year
or during werewolf by night in the halloween
special later this year the other big doctor
strange 2 ghost rider easter egg is at the end of
the movie when mcu doctor strange takes sinister
strange's darkhold and uses it to dreamwalk into
defender strange's body it winds up being a huge
marvel zombies easter egg on the side too we saw
a lot of that during the what if episodes but when
doctor strange does that the souls of the damned
attack him and they're meant to be like the souls
of people who are trapped in another hell-like
dimension forced to serve cosmic fearlords like
mephisto other major cosmic god tier villains like
cathone during the movie marvel used the spirits
of the dam to set up a concept of an unbalanced
spirit just trying to kill someone possess someone
just more setup for them explaining how the
ghost rider spirit of vengeance can exist
in the mcu how it works it's sort of like them
teasing the multiverse in the first doctor strange
movie then going full multiverse during marvel
phase four with things like spider-man no way home
things with doctor strange too the spirit of
vengeance that gives ghost rider his powers
at least at first in the comics is actually
the demon xerathos who is mephisto's enemy
that he just winds up enslaving and uses johnny
blaze and the other ghost riders as his pawns
it's sort of like cathone the god of chaos giving
scarlet witch her chaos magic when she was born
and then using her as a pawn to try and conquer
the entire multiverse during doctor strange 2.
that was what was going on with the whole
multiverse scarlet witch chaos magic plot
during the movie cathone is a completely different
character but he's doing the same thing that
mephisto for example would try to do or the other
fearlords using different types of characters to
conquer the mcu so all the stuff with the souls
of the dam the darkhold dreamwalking the god of
chaos the darkhold temple meant to be more occult
aspects that they're introducing in the movie
johnny blaise met mephisto for the first time when
he turned to the occult to use a spell to try and
cure his father's cancer and even though it wound
up being successful he wound up selling his soul
to do it forming a contract with mephisto kind
of like the contract that moon knight forms with
khonshu thus becoming ghostwriter so khonshu is
the god of vengeance in the mcu he's also the
god of the moon in the night sky so he forces
marc spector to take out evil people protecting
travelers of the night that's why marc spector
recites that very specific line during the series
mephisto basically does the same thing with johnny
blaze's ghostwriter taking out the forces of evil
but usually it's just other evil beings that
mephisto hates or is at war with himself because
mephisto already pretty evil but just like
moon knight in spite of what they're forced
to do by their respective gods they try to use
their powers for good things to be superheroes
ghostwriter has a ton of supernatural powers
that they've upgraded over the years that put him
on par with other really super powerful marvel
characters like his hellfire can burn people's
souls his penance stares probably his most famous
ability the penance stare just causes people to
regret everything terrible that they've ever done
so badly that they become totally incapacitated
with self-mortification even though the penance
stare is meant to be so powerful the only beings
that it doesn't work on are characters without
souls like the celestials for example wouldn't
work on them other demons who don't have souls
it doesn't work on characters who don't regret
their actions so for instance it would work on
thanos because he regretted having to kill gamora
and he does have a soul but it wouldn't work on
characters like the eternals because they don't
have souls they're like celestial robots it also
wouldn't work on characters like dormammu because
dormammu doesn't regret his actions and it also
doesn't work on characters who have some form
of divine protection from a god or a cosmic
being on them so for instance pennant stare
would not work on moon knight because moonite
has the protection of a god can't you but the
next big midnight sun's crossover that we're
supposed to be seeing in the mcu is reportedly
during werewolf by night which is happening this
halloween is a special the reason why werewolf by
night wasn't in the moonlight series they actually
revealed because kevin feige said he wanted to do
something different with the character during the
halloween special later this year so they're just
saving him for later this year mahershala ali's
blade character is supposed to appear during that
and then during the blade movie like i said
kid harrington's black knight character is
supposed to come back i think they're supposed
to have moon knight back and maybe werewolf by
night as well if you do have any more questions
though about how they're setting up ghost rider
in the mcu or other easter eggs that you've
spotted in recent episodes or recent movies
just write them below in the comments i'm working
on new fantastic four new x-men videos i'll try to
post those as soon as possible everyone click here
for my full doctor strange 2 breakdown for the
entire movie easter eggs for everything and click
here for my doctor strange 2 post credits scene
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!